this is Je
shirro 2019 model I'm going to program
all a smart Keys lost using launch door
Pro and using
the J cd1 cable okay this jcd 1 cable
I'm going to use it all the smart key is
lost so see let's how to do it go to
emo and go to
Jeep selected from Vel
North America
Shira
2019 Smart
Case red pin
code so
this CD cable is request okay s you
finish on as it is
all
okay is RIT pin code okay now going to
program case if you want to delete case
there is option you can delete the
original in case I don't want to delete
it because customer not request so I
just program the new
one switch inion off I keep the switch
imission is off and ha it is on press
enter so make sure there is no any devic
is nearby press
okay and this spin
code press it
okay so this you have to finish within
30 seconds okay keep the the remot is on
your
hand press okay and now just press the
unlock button
Twist on near by here it's success it so
now it's key is for so when you're
program you should get the hand is here
and press That's it programming complete
now you can check the
remote is going to work or no let's
close the door
[Music]
open where is the unlock where are
you just open and close the door
again maybe because device is connected
don't
know it's not a
issue yeah it's
working car is
starting and check the
REM so I can